[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
May 16th, 2016 how's it going? How are Ya? How's your life?
Are you liking your life? Are you enjoying your life? Do you hate your life?
Would you like to make a change? Well,
fortunately there's a solution with my new seven part eight track
tapes.
I'll help you turn around your life by making me a rich motherfucker first thing
you do. Um, anyways, I am in a great fucking mood.
It's actually a Sunday when I'm recording this. When I'm recording this,
it's Sunday. And, uh, I got the fucking
juices flowing. Bay
juices are flowing,
blood is flying through my system right now. Heart rate is fucking wonderful.
You know why?
Because I worked out the last two fucking days in a row in my brand new Jura.
Raj, fuck it.
Yeah.
Whoa. My New fucking gym. It's finally done. I went back and I picked up my,
uh, my truck. You know,
my old fucking Ford truck that I had a in storage while they finished it.
They did a phenomenal fucking job.
I outfitted the whole thing with a bunch of rogue fitness shit and um,
I never fucking show you my house. I might have to make a video.
I might have to show is a little fucker. Jim's a little cute. Jim,
I'll give you a little before and after, you know,
I might even wear my leg warmers for you.
I'll give you a quick fucking two second tour of the God damn thing.
I got my atomic holds up top and uh, I got to tell you all freckles,
old freckles lost a lot. A lot of what little he had. Holy Shit.
I went onto the pegboard. I, I felt like, you know, the,
for young first time you ever tried to do a pull up in your life, it's like,
it's almost like you were born without those muscles because you never use them.
You know what I mean? It's not like you go, oh, what's on top of the fridge?
You know, what do you do? You jump up and down, usually caps.
You don't grab the top of it and fucking pull yourself up.
Little stupid feet squeaking on the front of the fucking wait,
wait did you try to go up? Which is cheating by the way.
And if you ever made a video of it and you put it on Youtube,
I'm sure there would be hundreds of thousands of comments saying that it was an
epic fail refrigerator pull up. Cause people like when you fail,
you know why? Cause they don't like themselves. Um,
anyways, so it's done. And uh,
I'm so fucking psyched of course is a few, what little doodads we gotta do.
Nia wants an elliptical in there, you know,
which is fucking hilarious to me because she could give a rats fucking ass about
this gym and still until it started coming together and now she loves it,
you know?
But what's great is it's the garage and everybody knows that the woman,
the wife, the fucking the fucking lady over there,
everybody knows that they get the house but the guy gets the garage and see the
women think that they win cause they got the fucking house. Right.
You don't want the house. The House is where all the responsibilities,
the house is, where the bills come to the houses,
where the fucking people knock on the door and the cops come,
they go to the fucking house. Nobody, nobody goes to the garage.
The garage is fucking, its, it's genius. You know,
you act like it's a shit hole, blah.
And we'd go out to the garage and they're like, yeah, yeah.
Get out of the house. They don't give a fuck.
You go into the garage and that's it. Yeah. Just get no fucking idea.
You wait till I, I get one of those little fucking kegerators out there.
We're doing keg stands as I do curls, right.
Taking in calories as I burned them off at the same time while getting shit
faced. It's this new exercise video that I'm going to be putting out,
you know, I don't know what I would call it to get what you need. Alliteration,
right. Drunk dips or some shit like that. Right. Just to get people to buy it.
Alcoholic aerobics as too wordy too now. Too Wordy, too, too syllable. Lee,
I don't know. Whatever. I'll brainstorm on it. You know,
all you gotta do is just have a fucking headband on and people will buy the
video. If you promise them you're going to help him out, right?
You have a fucking headband on,
they spray a little fake sweat on you and then you know,
all you're going to get is a couple of hotties behind.
You're just smiling and shit, right?
The very least somebody can jerk off to it, right?
The next thing you know, they start flying off the fucking shelves.
And then what do you do yet? You're add onto the garage. Add on the garage.
I've told you guys forever my dream fucking house and my dream house.
I don't even know what the house looks like.
I just know what the garage looks like.
The garage don't you see as my dad loved to say the garage don't you see would
be a three car garage, right? One for me,
one for her and the other for whatever. My old fucking truck. All right.
And then upstairs they all, they'd be an upstairs,
the upstairs,
whatever gym and have a drum room and a fucking cigar bar slash fucking sports
bar. That's what it would be. Okay.
One door in, one door out,
maybe a fucking little ladder to go up onto the roof to buy you.
Right. And that's, I think if every fucking guy had that,
there's no fucking way.
You couldn't be a happily married man because you just could be in the house.
You got your kids running around. Everybody's freaking the fuck out. You know,
I need a break. I want to be fucking single, you know,
without the whois.
I just want to fucking just sit a drink without you fucking people in my car.
What's left of my hair. That's where the upstairs come sit.
And then you just go up there.
You have a great time while you slowly kill yourself, you know?
And then with every cigar you smoke and every drink you have and you know that
you're one close, one step closer to death,
which is a great thing because it's a release, you know?
I don't know. It started off happy. It got a little dark there towards the end.
You wouldn't know that I'm a happily married man, uh, by saying all that stuff,
but I also am by nature, I am a fucking loner. And,
uh, you know, I, I just, you know,
I just need to get away from people every once in awhile and I'm a do,
that would be the fucking Shit, you know, I have a couple of cool fucking dogs.
Those dogs that fucking lay around and like the howl, you know,
like a fucking bloodhound, right. Just sit there watching the game,
getting hammered, you know, soundproof walls. You can't hear your family,
you just sitting in there every once in a while you look over your,
your fucking bloodhound. A rusty, rusty woo.
The die would join with you. Yeah. Yeah. You fucking get it.
You fucking get it. Right.
I hope you enjoyed that because that fantasy, that man, I,
that's it right there. You know, I don't know what it is.
Some people want the White House, some people want a fucking Oscar.
And then some people just want,
would like to be able to get a Tan and have a two story fucking garage that said
, you know, I'm, I'm in part of that third group, part of the third group,
everybody. So anyways, um, I fucking went down there, um,
used all that rogue fitness shit that I bought and like I said, you know,
these guys are not paying me or anything like that.
They actually sent me those colorful weights.
Now I don't know what the fuck to do with them cause I have more weight than I
need. So I got some standup shows coming up in the La area.
If you're building a fucking gym, you know,
and um, oh, how do I go?
How do I make this a fair contest? I don't fucking know.
If you build in a gym and you listen to the podcast and you want some colorful
plates, some weights, uh,
I got them cause I was gonna take it over to play it again.
Sam's have played against sports, whatever the fuck they are,
but they just so God damn and Celtic, you know what I mean?
If you think that baldheaded comment on the, uh, the pawn shop show,
how we just fucking, you go in there and go, man, you got a bar,
a gold and the guys, they gay. You know how much you want for this? You're like,
well, the market value is fucking whatever, you know,
fucking $1,200 an ounce. Why don't you give me a,
give me a thousand amounts? And he's like,
so what you really want for it? But I, I on a fucking smash it over.
You've got fuck yourself.
Like what a fucking business people coming in selling their old fucking hair
dryers. You know their ass out, right?
And you've got to fucking take as much out of their crack as you can. I get it.
You know what? It's a business. I'm going to hard on that guy. God bless him.
God bless. Alright, so play it again. Sports is the same fucking way.
You'll come in with something with the price tag still on it now. God, yeah,
I'll give you like a dollar 50. You know what I mean? It's just like, I mean,
they make Richard Rollins look like a saint. Okay.
These fucking guys bust you down so bad. It's like whatever you're selling them.
It's like, how about I give it to you for free,
but I get to hit you over the head with it first. How about that?
Don't get me any fucking money.
I want to just mush it right in your fucking enough. I'm not doing that.
So I would rather give it to a podcast listener for free,
but I'm not shipping these fucking, yeah, thanks. Gets like a,
I don't know what it is. I think it's two 45 pound plates.
Two 30 fives. I don't know what it is.
They fucking big and they're heavy. That's all I know. Um,
whenever they're free free weights. So anyways, um,
went down there yesterday I did fucking chest and try today I did the, uh,
upper body stuff, all the body weight shit. Nia wanted this speed bag,
which I thought was a little fucking stupid. You know what I mean?
I always hated the speed bag unless you really train for a fight,
you know what I mean? [inaudible] to two, then you go to your fucking cubicle.
It always seems silly.
It just seemed fucking disrespectful to people actually fight for a fucking
living. Like the,
the level of respect that I have for people that do that for a fucking living.
Just the, the, the fucking courage it takes to do that. Um,
but of course now it's up there and I'm down there what it did
[inaudible] but what it did, data dump. Oh good.
Did that fuck data data that denim [inaudible] now of course,
now I'm going to get fucking obsessed with that shit.
I don't know when it's going to do for me.
I'm hoping it's going to bring my freckles out, you know? Um, anyway,
speaking of fights, did anybody watch UFC your up tree by day?
Not In the red corner. Did anybody see the UFC one 68, eight, eight, eight?
Um, it was basically, I think the USA or the world versus Brazil.
And I think Brazil once again proved that they are raw. You know,
if you want to fucking get into a fight slash be in the missionary position with
another person, if you think you're coming out on top of ain't happening,
they pretty much, they pretty much dominated the fucking night. But, uh,
except for this one guy,
and I'm not gonna know the names and actually tweeted the guy,
I'm still not gonna remember his name. He has a very fucking,
a unique name and it was fucking,
he fighting this guy and this guy's making all these silly faces when he's going
and they're going like the Brazilian dude,
I guess he was a champion or he is a champion. That's right. He's a champion.
And then he fucking a that Jesus Christ.
I was having a few when I was watching this, he fucking, he was fucking,
he was a champion and he was supposed to fight. He got hurt.
So we wanted to make sure he's 100% so he's coming down,
he's making all these silly faces and shit.
And I just remember the announcers going like, look, and I was like,
the biggest fight he's had in three years and he's making faces at the camera.
It's not even nervous. Right. All of this shit.
And then he comes to fucking white dude. He fucking, you know, old Dudley do,
right? He's got a police officer.
His hair cut you like this guy could have been a state trooper and he's fucking
coming down. And I'm like, all right,
well let's see what's going to go on here at the,
a white dude seems to be in a little better shape. The Brazilian guy,
surprisingly for a champion as a little bit of a dad bought,
you know what I mean? And a whatever. They start going at it and uh,
you know, white boys taken it a little bit, he's given it back, he's taken it,
whatever.
Then all of a sudden the Brazilian guy starts just running at him and he fucking
each one and he get in any regroups. He starts running man again.
And this fucking guy, the white too. What the fucking state trooper haircut.
He's backing up and as he's backing up,
it gives them just a little fucking little right there, Fred,
with the fucking a right hook, right? Well,
backing up and this fucking guy just, he just shut up. This guy's hard drive.
He just fucking pip and that guy,
let's just write down like a controlled implosion. You know,
when they take down a fucking building and everybody for some reason can take
off work to go down and watch it, you know, that's what they wasted sick day on.
Like, Hey, is any way I can breathe in that fucking a,
what do they call that shit? Not as fault. Oh Christ,
what the fuck do you call that shit? It's best dose, right?
They can breathe it in anyways, he fucking just hit the guy.
I keep just caught him the right way. I mean, granted, if he hit me with that,
I mean I would've been dead. There'd be no podcast ever again, you know? Um,
but he just caught the guy, I guess. Right?
And the guy just went right there like a ton of bricks.
He fucking went down and the fucking white dude just lost it. You know,
he just fucking,
he runs over to his corner claims those are going to get on the fence.
He went right up and over, hugged his whole team and just kept screaming.
I'm a fucking world champion. It was awesome.
Oh, sorry. Just blew out yours. It was fucking awesome. I get this too.
I think it's blue on my fucking ears.
It was just fun to see somebody like dad excited. And uh,
then of course they said that he was from Cleveland. So I tweeted out,
Cleveland finally won a champion championship and a,
that's why I think that's what I tweeted out or something like that. But um,
congratulations to that guy who I can't put, I don't,
I'm not gonna butcher his fucking name. Um,
it was awesome to see him win a championship.
It's great for the city of Cleveland. Right.
And even though it wasn't a team sport, you know, if you're in Cleveland,
you gotta be, you know, when you won't be thinking this. Cause you guys,
you know, you've been beaten,
you've been beaten down by this sports gods for so long that you guys really,
uh, you're afraid of having hope.
But I remember reading about Christopher Columbus when he came over to the,
the, the Americas, which he thought was, I don't know, India.
I don't know what the fuck he thought. Um, before he got to land,
there was a couple of branches before he got the land and he started either,
you know,
being nice people or chopping off people's hands because they wouldn't give them
their gold fillings. Uh, depending on what movie you believe, you know,
I always love that new studies find, it's like, what,
where the fuck was this information? Was it,
was it on a cocktail Napkin and somebody finally looked at it? Huh?
Did you find one of those scrolls? Was it written by somebody? Hey, by the way,
this is what really happened.
And somebody just kept it for years and they just let the lie go and go and go.
And then, or maybe maybe the people that survived what he did,
they had this shit written down. I don't know.
I think I'm fucking way off track here. Where the hell am I? Oh yes. So anyways,
he's either way before he fucking got to land any that was a halfway decent guy
or an absolute fucking war criminal, depending on what you belief.
Either wait till you get the day off. You know,
sometimes people got to die to get a fucking day off. You know,
when you really think about it. Um, anyways,
the fuck was I talking about? Yeah. You see some fucking branches and shit.
So there you go. But guy from Cleveland is a champion. All right.
It starts with wants to now. You gotta be looking at the Cavaliers.
I don't think they've lost yet. You know, it's funny.
Everybody in Cleveland right now is going, shit. All right, I'll shut up.
Just say it. Um, that's another weird city.
Part of me wants Cleveland to win,
but there's just such a hilarious misery to the Cleveland Sports Fan.
I almost want to see it keep going.
So I guess I'm going to be happy either way. I was really surprised at okay.
See beat, uh, beat the Spurs. Um, considering I never watched,
but I just watched the Celtics, but I was hoping that, um,
I was hoping that uh, Tim Dunkin was going to get his sixth ring, you know,
just so I'd have yet another thing to say to fucking lake offense when they
bring up Koby Bryant. Well, another guy during Kobe's time, he wants six.
He was a team player. That one, he really blew the ball.
Everybody involved, uh,
didn't need fucking 90 million free agents to come in and help 'em out every
fucking year. All right, sorry. Anyway, so let's plow ahead here. Um,
what am I talking about here? So, yeah, so congratulations. And um,
I was disappointed with the Cyborg fight. You know what I mean?
I would sit in there going like, yeah, I know. I want to see this shit fight.
I want to see that, you know, and you know,
I gotta tell you the women's fights are usually better than the men's.
I don't know why they go on it like they go on at like fucking alley cats.
It's crazy. Um, I just don't understand how they can just,
how you can just kick somebody in with the bare foot and it doesn't hurt you to,
you know,
they should fucking have just regular people like me just go in and do MMA shit
to each other and just watch this both crumble after the first strike punch once
with your hand at fuck, you know, you put in under your armpit. Um, anyways,
but she fought some chicks. She was like eight, six, and one. So I'm like,
what the fuck? She's going to destroy it.
This is going to be over in the first round. And then Lo and behold, Jesus,
she fucking hits hard. She fucking,
which is rain and punches. And the other woman was, was, you know, still pulls,
getting hurt,
was doing way better than I would have one jab and I would've been on my back.
But she was fucking eating them for well for a minute. And then she went down.
And then there was a moment when she was always moving,
but it looked like she was out and the guy stopped the fight. Right.
Which he should I think was right to stop the fight.
So in the end when they have the official decision,
they cut to her right. And now, and everybody cheers. She's Brazilian.
It's a hometown crowd. And when they cut to the other,
the woman who lost sheets, like holding back tears and she's just looking up,
this is why I love this fighter forever. She was just looking up at the fucking,
the diamond vision thing, whatever, the big screen. And she waited, she,
she was on the scoreboard and the second she was on the scoreboard,
she just goes,
they were fucking tax. They were fucking tapped.
And the whole place Buddha [inaudible]
she was so fucking mad. Um,
which is understandable.
I mean I can't imagine trained in that fucking long and that God damn hard and
then it's just over in like three minutes. Um, it must have been brutal. But,
um, I dunno. She was great. She was all hard.
So hopefully she'll come back or whatever. I don't know.
I was really into that last one and I, that Cleveland Guy was hilarious. He was,
he was talking to me. He was like, you know, and I know everybody here,
you don't like me cause we're in Brazil, but you guys make the sport great.
You called them out on it. You know,
you're not voting for me cause I'm a fucking
cause I'm from Cleveland. He should've been. But I'm from Cleveland.
I'm used to this. Um, anyways,
let's see here. I don't know if I have any advertising here. Um,
hang on one second. In the meantime, I'll tell you a quick story.
You guys are all well aware that the, uh, the juniors prince died.
Did you guys see that? Did you get that in your papers? So anyways,
out here in Beverly Hills, they're having an auction on one of his guitars.
See Yellow one that he did.
[inaudible] how many fucking times I've got to type in my fucking password.
Come on. Uh,
maybe cause I can't fucking remember it. Like that fucked it up again.
Third Time to children, Eh,
and have to hum what it is or I fuck it up.
Can you imagine being this dumb and actually fucking having your own gym?
It's kind of dangerous, isn't it? Alright. So e m
they're auctioning off one of his guitars. It was the one that he used with the,
the new power generation, the cream album, I believe.
And somebody bought it a few ago. I can't believe it was even for sale,
but some guitar collector admittedly doesn't play and we just collect some,
he paid 30 grand for this fucking thing. So he says,
I should read this word for fucking word. This is so fucking priceless.
And he says like, the reason why he's selling it is because,
you know, it's become, you know, with the passing of prince,
it's become so valuable. Um,
daddy's actually nervous to have it. He's nervous to own the fucking thing.
Right. Which is, fuck it. It's, it's like, dude,
why don't you just say, you know what, the guy fucking just died.
Everybody's paying attention. This is a great time to sell this fucking guitar.
I'm trying to make money off of this guy's death. Um,
why can't you just say that? You know, I hear it. Is Prince's guitar.
All right. I got to read with this guy. Said it's just the way they, well,
there's nothing wrong with it. You want to make a buck just, you know,
the guy died and I'm trying to make fucking money off of it. All right. Um, but,
but bubba yellow car case goes,
I've been a prince fan since I was a little kid and that guitar always stuck out
to me because it was super cool and stylish. Said the current owner,
he paid about 30 grand for it. He said, unfortunately, as morbid as it is,
when people pass, their items become more valuable.
I think something as valuable as this could be too risky to continue to have in
my possession. He's worried about his safety. Get the fuck Outta here, man.
You're trying to make some money trying to make, give me,
you're trying to make some money. That's so fucking creepy.
It's a really cool looking guitar,
but I don't think I could own a guitar of a dead person who was way better at
playing than I'll ever be. Um,
I feel like that should be in like the rock and roll hall of fame so people can
just go and, and look at it. Stay in your house.
How fucking weird would that be? Just having people over and people going.
Is that, is it? Yeah, that's Prince's guitar.
I would immediately be whispering to my wife going, this guy fucking killed.
Let's get outta here. Fuck. Does he have his guitar?
It would immediately creep me up, but that's me. You know,
I'm a paranoid son of a bitch. He wants a fucking two story garage. Sue me.
Do I not have any fucking reads this week?
I think I might have advertisers that, I don't know if you guys have noticed,
but I've slowly but surely pissed all of them off. Um, no.
Well, well maybe, maybe. I do have some advertising. He just hasn't sent it.
Nope. I'm hitting the refresh button. I don't fucking see it now. You know what,
why they still sense it. Don't they understand that if I shit on it,
you guys actually listened to it and then maybe you'll buy it as opposed to just
fast forwarding through all of it. That's what I tried to do. I mean I'm just,
you know, I'm trying to help them make money right now.
What the fuck you going to do? Well, speaking of, you know,
I played for about five,
six years and then I stopped over the last couple of years when the downstairs
was being redone and then I recently got back into it. But you know,
this is the deal. I play drums I fuck around and guitar and um,
I've always wanted one of those lemon burst fucking uh, less pulse.
I'm trying to find one, a lefthanded one. I just think it's fucking,
I dunno, but you know what kills me whenever I get to get a guitar associate,
Les Paul, I just started thinking of all the fucking great music I've,
I've heard coming out of that thing. And then when I pick it up it's just like,
oh Jesus,
am I the asshole that just bought a fucking guitar he doesn't deserve.
I think I am. All right,
I'm going to pause here just so I can just fucking, if I get advertising later,
I can just put it in here. Um, or maybe not.
So maybe if they'll see, let's see what happens. All right.
Pausing here for some advertising that might be read later.
All right, I'm back. Did I read anything? I Dunno.
I guess I'll find out later. Anyway, so, um,
it's only four 27 here, Pacific coast time and in 33 minutes,
the blues, San Jose Schatz, fucking, um,
game starts and, um,
I can't tell you how fucking excited I am about this and I already know how
they're probably gonna sell this game. That's a tale of two cities,
two cities that have never gotten over the hump.
They're fans of add more heartbreak than a fucking unbelievable bloon and
fucking spirit through the chest. One thing for sure,
for one city, they'll be moving on to the Stanley Cup final,
not finals, as I always say,
the Stanley Cup final and for the other team,
more misery when neither one should be ashamed.
Lave both knocked off between the two of humble to perennial giants in the west
with the La cakes and the fucking Chicago Blackhawks, right?
They're going to do some shit like that.
Somebody is going to make it to the Stanley Cup final. I hate that.
It's the final. I like the finals and I hate when people go, Ooh,
this is all we Wolfel [inaudible], Bootsy, NBA fair,
but there's seven games. It's the finals, right? I'd have no problem with that,
plural. That's a great thing. You know when people go like, yeah,
all those cuts over there in Europe or around the world go,
why do you call it football?
You know
ours make sense. It's football and somebody goes, all right,
if you want to be tentacle,
you should call it feet ball you use in both your feet.
Why do you call football? There you'd go, you'd dribble right back and forth
between your feet so much called feet ball, Fidi ball footsie,
which called footsie. In other words, why don't you go fuck yourself? Um,
anyways, uh, I am really excited about this and um, what I would like to do,
don't you see is I would like to have, uh,
what am I giant ice cubes with some fucking booze in it.
Cause I booze hard on the weekends cause I fucking stare at a goddamn script all
week before I come home and booze heart,
who's getting to my drinking is out of control. Um,
I think this is why people have children at some point in their life.
Cause if you don't, you just drink yourself to death.
I'll tell you, it's fun. It's a funny than shit diapers. Um, anyways, I am,
uh, I'm nervous about this one. I'm nervous.
I had a belief that the blues were going to get by the Blackhawks.
I'm not kidding. I'm a surprise. And, uh,
I had a belief that they could get by the, uh, the Dallas stars,
but certainly with the goaltending issues,
which I didn't even know they fucking had. Um, that still went seven.
So I figured this would make sense that you get to the next,
each day you get a little blood tested.
So I want to say whoever wins this is gonna fucking win the Stanley Cup in the
Stanley Cup, Stanley Cup final. Um,
but I was hanging out with Barnick last night and he knows more about hockey
than I know about myself. And he was saying that, uh,
he thinks Tampa Bay lightning know even though they goaltender went down.
So we shall see. Um, I'm sticking with the blues. Me, me,
St Louis, Louis, Louie, me at the fair, I'm sticking with the blues.
That's my team. And um, cause my real team, the Bruins didn't make it,
but I still love him. I'm going to be there again in October,
and if they play the blues, I'm not going to give a fuck.
If they beat him fucking whatever, 12 to nothing, I will give a shit. Um,
speaking of which somebody sent me something about, um, you know,
people always love to make points on all the dumb shit that I say on Twitter.
Like, I mean, how many times do I have to admit that I'm a fucking moron?
You really don't need to correct me.
I realize that I'm an idiot but somebody goes stick to it.
It's not a lot of scoring and soccer and sends me like one day's worth of
fucking scores. It's just like,
okay well if you average it out I think I'm right. You know,
you know what's funny about that fucking Lester City Championship.
Do you know how they found out that that they wanted championship cause two
other teams played to like a one one tie.
There wasn't even a play off play off. There wasn't even a fucking playoff.
Like here we go. This is it.
We're down to the final two fucking teams.
We're going to play for 19 hours and hopefully at some point somebody's going to
put the fucking ball and then in the net and the goal, whatever,
and then it's going to be over,
except it's going to be injury time that nobody knows what it is except for the
fucking, uh, the refs and everybody starts whistling.
I didn't even have that.
They watched these two other teams play to a tie and then everybody went crazy.
That seems really anticlimactic to me.
I think he wants somebody to fucking kick the ball.
It goes into the fucking somebody scores. Right.
And then collectively as sports fans, you all fucking bust your nut. Ah,
when it goes in. Yeah,
just a bunch of people walking around with scarves,
watching somebody with wind get a fucking tie.
And then you're excited about that. I, I don't, I, I don't get that.
You know,
you would think that a country that survived the fucking blitzkrieg like that
level of excitement in your fucking life,
you think you think that your sports would, were, would reflect it.
Maybe you had and maybe your fucking grandparents had enough fucking excitement
for one lifetime annual lifetime too. So they just started watching that.
I don't know. Well,
maybe I don't understand enough about the game and I'm just a fucking moron.
Maybe that's what it is. I don't know. I have no idea. Whatever. Go,
go get some fucking fish and chips and go fuck yourself. All right, let's read.
Let's read some. Um, let's read some, uh,
some of this bullshit here that I got from this week. Um, oh, by the way,
I had a great weekend down and uh, before I get to this, I got an hour to fill,
so don't worry about it. Um,
yeah.
Oh, I had a great weekend.
Have I've just been in a real slump as far as writing new bits,
just because, uh, my life is ground to a halt here. It's like,
you know, I'm not going out. I'm not doing anything.
It's like my wife went to the Beyonce concert last night at a, at the Rose Bowl,
and I was actually thinking I should gone because there's no fucking way I
wouldn't have got a bit out of that. I would have felt old.
That would've felt stupid. I wouldn't know what the songs,
when she come out fucking whipping her weave around and shit.
That'd be something I could talk about. Right. Um,
but instead I went down to the comedy store and I did a couple of shows and, um,
I actually went out, let's have a comedians.
They're out there and I was just so fucking sick of doing the same shit and
trying to make it work. I just, every once in a while, if you just go out there
and, uh, you just not thinking anything and you just start fucking talking,
it works way better and it breathes his new life into all your jokes.
I just kind of went out there and, um,
which is a very terrifying thing to do when you,
if you've never done that in standup because you really feel like you're, uh,
you know,
do you remember in like the Matrix when Keanu Reeves to trying to convince them
to fucking step off that building and he's not gonna fall to his death?
All he has to do is Billy isn't,
was it that movie or was it fucking Battlestar Galactica?
Moonraker I don't know what the phone of those space movies, right.
It wasn't even space, but Scifi, um,
he had to like believe it and if you believe it, then you find if you,
if you don't believe it, you actually fall to your death.
This is sort of one of those things, but of course you're not gonna die.
You're just gonna, you know,
metaphorically die on stage is his basic stepping off the building is basically
you just leaving your act behind and just fucking just talking.
So I just went out there and I just started riffing the fact that I made a smart
move by not going to be on say, because you know,
when I went to Lady Gaga with my wife,
um,
you know, I fucking,
I mean she was mad at me for like three fucking days after that one in defense
of me, which there really, really is no defense. I watched the Patriots,
we lost I think two a, the ravens in the playoffs during the day.
So I was already drinking. I already had like good six pack in me. And then, uh,
we took a car service to fucking lady Gaga and we went on the thing and it was,
uh, it's, you know, I'm all about seeing the band.
I want to see the drummer and all that type of shit. And she,
on this tour for whatever reason, it's hard towards her choice,
whatever she had them in. Like this house,
there was a fucking house and I couldn't see the drummer.
There was like a window. I could kind of see his hands a little bit,
a little bit of his head. And that was it. And it was just like, fuck,
I want to see the band. And um, I can't,
it was so long ago, I don't remember what the fuck,
but I just started telling that story and how I fucking pissed her off.
And then if I went to the Beyonce thing, you know how I would, I would just,
you know, you know,
when they sang like that independent woman's song and everything,
just a dirty looks,
I'd be given most of the women there knowing that they were full of shit and
that they shouldn't be putting their hands up in the air. You know,
it was just a smart move that I didn't go and my wife still has never gotten
over my behavior at the lady Gaga concert to the point that I actually asked her
to come on the podcast to talk about the Beyonce concert.
And she just goes now and I try not to laugh.
I tried to hold it together. I go, what do you mean though? She goes,
we think I'm a fucking idiot. No, she goes,
I'm not going on the podcast and give you, giving you a, a,
an opportunity to start trashing Beyonce. I'm not going to trash Beyonce. Great.
I have to admit, she started showing me
okay.
Video clips of the concert and she had it like the way she was whole,
she was, we were on the couch and she snuggled up next to me.
So she's holding the kind of low to my, you know, near my stomach.
And like three times I started laughing, looking at the, uh,
looking at the clips. Um, and look, dude,
I know she's way more talented than I could ever be out and I don't even
remotely put on show, but this,
this just something funny to me about when everybody dances in unison and they
have that, you know, that angry look on their face.
It's just the funniest for assists. Like what is your, what is the problem
coming up? They got their arms out, you know,
and they doing that little fucking thing with their head and their feet are
running. Uh, it's just, I can't,
I can't even dance like the fucking nerve of me to laugh at it,
but it always strikes. It's just,
it is absolutely ridiculous. Something, it's,
I understand why it's awesome and people appreciate it,
but it's also really fucking funny to me. I should say.
I don't know why. Maybe I, you know what? I'm just a con. Don't listen to me,
so whatever.
So I made a great fucking move by not going to that concert.
Made a very smart, married a couple of years getting a wise,
in my old age, I just was just like, you know what? I can, that's,
that's the best. When you start,
you start to know somebody and yourself well enough to be like, you know what?
I see the fight coming. You know what I mean? It's actually,
it's like slipping punches, which I, there's something else.
Another reason why I suck at fighting is you could literally tell me on
Thursday,
I'm throwing this punch at this time and you would still not only catch me with
it, you [inaudible] your whole hand or foot or whatever, would you,
I just can't do it. I, I, you know, whatever, I stink at it. So,
um, I saw this fight comment and I was just like,
I was like all right now and I gave my, you know,
my ticket away and she took one of her girlfriends.
So I look good with the friends and all of that fucking shit. And uh,
I avoided a major fucking fight and I just went on stage cause I was like,
I'm sick of my jokes. That was the point of this shit. I'm sick of my jokes,
so whenever I get into this, these, um,
whatever you've got writer's block, even though I don't write whatever,
just riffing block I guess cause I just sort of wing my shit.
Um,
okay.
I just say to myself, what am I thinking right now? What am I feeling?
And I was feeling,
thank God I didn't go to Beyonce because me and my wife would get into a big
fight. So, and you know, it's funny, I didn't even make that decision.
I kind of as I was don, I rare brought me up.
He gives the best fucking intros. He said this fucking in Troy because you know,
this next guy come to the stage. Uh, you know, he never made me laugh.
You know, immediately people are just dying. They just fucking,
he just does that stuff. But, you know, people seem to enjoy him. Um,
I dunno. I've written a lot of his stuff and just, you know,
just making me look like a complete asshole.
So I went out there and it wasn't until after I shook his hand that I was
actually thinking of the first bit I was gonna do and I was just like, Oh God,
this is gonna feel like shit coming out of my mouth. I can't even say it.
And then I just over the years have just knowing that trick. I was just like,
what am I feeling right now? I was just feeling,
I'm glad I fucking did go to Beyonce cause I get new three day fight with my
wife and I just started talking about that and it just,
it worked.
And then I had this other chunk of material and I did the last joke without even
setting it up from the other shit. And it still worked.
It just worked in a different way. And um, it was,
it was great.
It may be fucking love stand up again cause I was really not like I didn't,
whenever I hate stand up, but just this whole fucking writing every day.
All right.
Alright. And now through the magic of technology is now, uh,
10 oh one Pacific coast time and I'm watching the third period of uh,
St Louis, San Jose. Um,
I take the fucking game for greater check to go to the first two periods.
Who won St Louis so far? Alright,
let's shoot these fucking ads and get on with the fucking Washington,
the sports here. All right, boy, uh,
you need to know how to cook unless you get a broad your license.
She's old tools. You know what I mean?
Not only do you feel like you know you were around the kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier and trading money instead of ordering
expensive takeout all over again. But where do you start?
Who Apron as you covered for the last 10 less than $10 per meal we'll wait from
delivers all the fresh ingredients and you need to create home cooked meal,
Jeff Ball to easy step by step instruction. Use new brass. You look really good.
We should move around. When I was a single seller,
each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store and no more sad take out and that a
how dietary preferences, no matter your dietary preferences.
We'll wait for the mix of the bleeds to discover and prepare dishes like seared
salmon with asparagus and new potato Hash and creamy AOE right in your own
kitchen. I don't even know what half of that is. Who the
fuck is they only
cook with ingredients that you've never used before? Like watermelon, radishes,
sterile, Farro,
modal and purple potatoes and red puppies are between 500 and 700 calories per
portion. Delicious and good for you right now.
You can get your first two meals for free, yet we wait for Dotcom.
Flash for that blue wave for.com press for
Glasper. A better way to cook. Oh, here we go. Me On d v R and D,
no more sweaty balls. The do do me on these.
Me On the gum drinking amigos mark, pour it down.
The front of my fucking underwear dries up real quick and I don't care my balls
good. Drunken so am I by the fucking penny.
Your queen is all right near knees. Whether you're wearing a suit or
whether you're wearing a suit or sweat,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear unless you're Matthew
mcconaughey and you're aware of this.
She is run down the beach carrying a couple of her, whatever the fuck it is,
he goes on TV. That's amazing. Anyway,
but instead of making a statement like superman under his everyday clothes,
your underwear is probably boring. The undies is here to change that. Well,
you know, it's pretty boring as it, it's just red. Yeah.
So you have his fucking name on it. That's when it gets interesting.
Please include all the volume point. Why would not, you're rolling.
I'm going to read it. Modal is pronounced modal every pair of me.
And these is made from sustainable mode out of press fabric twice as soft as
cotton, allegedly. Nothing can describe the fit and the feel of the on these.
You gotta feel it up against you, evolved to appreciate it.
But once you find them on your,
understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
And if yellow on your first parently on these, there no questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear. Were there any more you can see them or not?
Remember Superman. Um,
they're really great marketing and spoke towards the comic con Crowder.
They can give a fuck about superman. Didn't he lose the Batman
shipping at three in the US and Canada and you can save up to $8.
Prepare with me. I'm used to get the subscription or a single pair,
get points done off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
four for 20% off your first order. And then here we go. The final one,
legal film,
five things you can count on when using legal zoom for your business.
Number one, more than a million people have already trusted legal them to stop.
Start that business and corporations, LLC, nonprofits, PDAs,
whatever the fuck those are in more use,
legal zoom to get started the right way. Uh,
number two,
the deuce serious you can put on legal zoom for all that you can come on Eagle
Hill for all the details. They helped a,
they've been helping all types of businesses, owners for over 15 years. Numbers,
twats numerals, helpful support.
They have the right people standing by ready to help you with your questions.
All based in the United States. Woo shot, fired India.
Um, number, no modal. Um, legal advice.
Legal isn't a law firm,
so they built the network of independent attorneys available in scoring eight
states.
You get answers to your legal questions and they can review supplier contracts,
employment laws, and help with most of the day to day situations that pop up.
And finally, letter B, a, B, c,
d, e, that's the first one. Um,
when adults say they looked in the web, you don't learn another concept.
10 Spanish lessons, not block with my dog.
When somebody get knocked down all show,
like you're going to get the fuck up or what's called Asheville,
make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today. And don't forget to
enterBerg@checkouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com. Alright,
that's exactly the Parkchester. [inaudible]
let's get to some questions here for this week. Oh, look what's back.
So yeah.
Oh, see,
oh good.
Um, speaking of which, how greatest song is top Jimmy, I fucking love that song.
All right. SCIATICA. Uh, hey bill, love your podcast.
I wanted to tell you about my sister's cure for s a SCIATICA lie,
but don't worse. Joe's gay clog. Um,
the providence say they at one night only shy
my ass fucking, um,
she suffered from Sciatica, uh, for years. For years.
Her doctor recommended she see a Pajama podiatrist.
That's a foot doctor for all you civilians out there who filmed her from behind
woo fucking creep as she walked on a treadmill. Yeah. Hey Man,
what do these yoga pants, by the way,
I don't understand why guys are fucking so obsessed with yoga pants.
I've never been at yoga pants. I like just, you know what,
I took too many yoga classes.
I just know what the room smells like and I just feel like that's what you clam
smells like when you wear those. And I know that's immature. I'm sorry. Um,
he immediately saw her right foot was rolling out as she walked.
He said this was causing her problems with Sciatica and he made custom orthotic
shoes, inserts that she wears most of the time.
She said this worked immediately to completely eliminate her pain from Sadeka.
Oh, oh, oh, oh. Um, she said after you start wearing the orthotics,
you should visit a chiropractor to get everything back in alignment and you're
good to go. Give it a try and go fuck yourself. Thank you so much for that. Um,
I don't think I have that issue, but I,
I got the name of a good chiropractor and you know what, dammit,
when I'm uploading this podcast,
I'm actually going to go see a doctor because somebody sent me this thing on,
um, on Twitter. Go Bill, go see a doctor.
Jesus did we learn nothing from so and so.
And it was somebody who was on Letterman who was,
she had a shortness of breath and he kept blowing it off.
He kept talking to people who weren't doctors and they're like,
I'm sure you find,
I'm sure you find that he found out it was fucking lung cancer.
Obviously that's not what I'm looking at here. Um, all right.
Uh, so I will definitely go. Thank you for that. All right, number two, uh,
Duke, where will Katelyn take a shit this week?
Um, number two. Hi Bill.
I was a wall and floor Tyler for 27 years and my to,
for any lower back pain was a gel ice in lying on a hard floor.
The Gel pack molds to the area that is sore and the hard floor keeps you spine
flat. Lie on your back.
Weight lie on your back on the floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice in. What does that mean?
They bend in and lift them up or just have your feet on the floor.
Um, do you put your foot down on a two? You jump up on the wound. Ah,
sorry. Thinking about prince now. All right. Um,
then we'll the ice pack and then try it way, way, way, way, way.
I missed the whole fucking thing. Lie on your back.
Okay.
You know what it as he wrote a bunch of words that are all like the same.
I have some sort of fucking dyslexia because he has lie like a bunch of times in
feet. Lie on your back on the floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice pack at the spot, giving you trouble. Leave it there. Oh,
I know why he didn't have any punctuation. Leave it there for 15 minutes.
You can watch TV doing this then moves the ice pack and then try to feel like
you are pressing your spine into the floor.
Continue with the treatment once or twice a day until you feel better.
I hope this works for you.
I loved efforts for family and reminded me of my childhood and I'm a 57 year old
Australian male. Love the specials in the podcast. Help you get better soon.
Well that's good to know. So you're 10 years older than me.
Well that should work because we kind of age bill a little bit older than,
than I was in 1973 or 74.
He's about 11 years old and which would mean he would have been,
would have been born in 62 so that's right in your wheelhouse,
right? You would probably be born in like what,
58 59 yeah, belt. That's how the math works out. All right, cool.
Um, okay. Australia mailbox full.
Thank you so much for watching and please tell more people down there in
Australia if you can to check it out. Um,
I actually heard a lot of times people say to put heat on your back ice I guess
is better. Uh,
cause if you have any sort of a inflammation in the nerve or something like
that, I dunno, I've been using a leaf and doing these stretches,
I feel much better and I haven't been sitting down at all.
I've actually been squatting like a Vietnamese gambler and, um,
I don't know. I, uh, that's been working for me in these stretches.
I still haven't quite gotten it better, but I'm going to walk,
go to a chiropractor and get adjusted out Jesus. And you know what? I that,
and I also need glasses finally giving into that because my, um,
every two years when your of my advanced age, you got to go get a physical,
physical, a Waldo again physical.
Um, I got my pilot's license. So you got to every, you know,
if you're a younger fella, every four lady lady, every five years you,
you got to renew your medical, um, you got to get it updated. So with me,
it's every two fucking years and I barely made it through.
And I'm literally like, what the fuck am I doing here?
I don't want to wear glasses, just don't,
I just don't want to have another fucking thing that I have to deal with.
And I also have this paranoia that all glasses do is make you fucking eyes
worse. Kinda like a chap stick. It just dries out your lips even more.
That's like the big urban myth. And then you get addicted to it,
then you got to use it, you know, whatever. I have dry ass lips.
I just use a little Vaseline, works like a fucking charm.
And then I just started pounding waters and then you find you fucking find that
fucking chapstick and all that shit. I don't like it.
I don't like it makes me have weird dreams, you know,
get that chemical in there and seeps right in the fucking face.
And it goes right to your brain. And next thing you know,
you just run around with an ax and your drained. You may have a dream like that.
Some reason you're screaming, answer me, uh,
I'm just making this shit up people at all. I don't,
what the fuck you want from me? Usually the,
the advertising takes up a little bit of time and I don't have any four 48
another 12 minutes. And then the game stats. Oh,
and I got another 15 minutes here. Fuck. Well thank you.
Thank God for Teebo right. All right. Grass killing name.
Alright. Uh, fantasy, revenge advice.
Hello billion. I'm a 23 year old male.
I live with my parents in the country that even Australia makes an oh wow.
That even Australia makes fun of too from uh, Australians here. Oh, New Zealand.
Oh Jesus.
I live with my parents in a country that even Australia make fun of New Zealand.
I thought you meant a part of a country. I can't read people.
I love emphasis for family and can't wait for season two. Thank you so much.
Please tell more people in New Zealand about it if you haven't already,
if he got the time.
I'm not trying to put you out if you don't want to be that Douche,
don't be the Douche. But if you do, I'd appreciate it. All right, so here we go.
Fantasy, revenge. Advice sometime ago,
my father was using a lawn trimmer on the right side of the front yard,
which is only a few feet from our neighbor's driveway while trimming the edges
of small rock in the grass,
shot out and hit our neighbors parked car in the driveway.
Our neighbor was already at the front of his house and either saw or heard the
bang and started yelling at my dad who was apologetic.
The rock the rock put a small dent in the car,
which was hard to see even close up when I, when I was told what happened,
my dad by my dad, I was a little pissed that he yelled,
but I knew he had a right to be upset. And although it was an accident,
my dad would happily pay for the damages because he knew he was at fault.
Um, our neighbor didn't talk to us again about a bill or anything,
so we quickly forgot about it and moved on. A few weeks later,
I was at the front of our house that I saw that the right side of our lawn was
completely dead, of foot inwards.
I realized this fucking con had poisoned the area of the grass that would
usually be cut using the trimmer. Wow.
This guy's got major communication issues.
So this incident would never happen again. The state might,
despite my dad telling him that he would only mow the lawn when the driveway was
empty in the future. Um,
I asked my dad if he knew anything and he told me he had known for a few days,
but didn't want to make a big deal about it.
My Dad is a very easy going guy who doesn't get bothered much myself on the
other hand, spent the night, uh,
the next few nights fantasizing about revenge. Oh,
it looks like you take after your mom. All right. Get Dad's easygoing.
He married a fucking a hot blooded woman and she, you know, she calmed her down,
right? And then you, you, you, you got her fucking DNA. All right. I like,
I like where this is going so far, even though I'm not a big revenge guy.
Your Dad's easygoing. It's his house already. My Gut say,
and your dad's easygoing. It's his fucking house. You know? Um,
don't do anything to disrupt it. Um,
you said that I thought about doing the exact same thing to his lungs,
but spelling out the words coward. Oh my God, that's fucking hilarious.
I've thought about pulling out all of his plants and dumping it on his car to
send a message.
It's been a few months and I still get pissed off when I think about it,
but I decided not to stoop to his level and pull off a bitch move like that.
The only option would be to confront him,
but there is no scenario in which that would end. Well, why not?
Um, why not? Why can't you just next time you see him, just say like, dude,
I gotta tell you something. I haven't been on this planet for a long time,
so maybe I need to see more bitchy behavior, but that's the biggest pussy bitch.
Fucking mad. I don't do that. It's going to, I don't know. I would just say,
Hey, do you have any idea why this part of the lawn died? Isn't that amazing?
And I would do that to them every fucking time.
Just do something that drive them nuts anyways,
cause I've decided to do nothing and moved on,
but it's been about a year and I'm still thinking about it.
What would you have done? Am I justified to be pissed? This pissed?
And how the fuck do I stop myself from letting it get me in such a bad mood
every time I walked past our front lawn and see the dead strip of lawn?
Thanks for listening, Bill. Come back to New Zealand. Um,
your lawn is still dead. Look,
I'm not a big on revenge,
but the great thing that you have right now is you've waited a year.
Um,
so if you were to do anything,
obviously don't bring any physical harm to the person. Um,
he does seem to love that car.
It's just, yeah, why would you do it?
Um,
why don't you guys read, just replant the fucking grass.
That's what I would do. I would replant the grass. This is what you do.
Replant the grass and get all excited.
And then without him knowing what you do is you set up a fucking video camera.
All right? And he just videotape. And you, you try to catch them doing it.
That's the best way to do it. Right.
And then he has to fucking pay for it and then pay for the previous thing.
The previous, he poisoned it. Like that's what I would do. You know what I mean?
There's obvious things that you could do.
You could go to a fucking auto zone and buy one of those little catch trays that
captures oil, you know? And then in the night you could undo his fucking
let all the oil out of his car on screwed the thing on the oil pan and you'd
screw it back up and then he seizes the edge on his car. You can go that route.
Okay.
You know, there's no oil in the fucking car. Um
Hm.
The key is what you have to do is
he would still figure it out,
see if he can't do this is all bitchy fucking moves. You know what I mean?
You got to have a face to face thing.
Or what I would do is I would just repat pre plant the grass and I would set up
a fucking video camera and maybe just say that. Just say, hey, just so you know,
if you plan on poisoning our grass,
cause I know you're not a man and you would never say anything to my dad's on my
self's face. You know, just let you know I got the security.
You're going to be on video and we're going to catch you doing it. Okay.
All right. It costs us a lot of money and I year I, oh my God, what a,
in a perfect world,
could you just go over and just fucking take this answers the door and you go
and you just boot them right in the nuts, huh? You would do.
Then you just take a strip of the dead grassy to start fucking beating his back
with it. That's what the fuck you wanted to. I, you know what?
I actually want to do that right now, but you know what? You can't do it.
You know what? Fuck him. He did it to you. He did it to you.
Oh Dude, you know something. I think you're,
I think what you came up with is the best.
Why don't you just write coward? Nah.
Cause then he's going to do something else to your dad's house.
Okay.
Oh, this guy's a cunt. You know what?
He doesn't have the balls to confront your dad.
So when I think you do yet do the little cower thing and then set up video
cameras and catch them doing something else,
but then you've done something to him. See it's just, it's just awful.
It's just as bitchy tit for fucking tat thing. I don't know what you have to do,
but I feel like something has to be said. At least
I know what you'd do. This is what you do.
You go down to a fucking lady shoe store.
Okay.
All right. And you buy a cheap pair of fucking women's shoes.
And next time you see you wrap it up like a present and you just give a two
and there's a card in there and everything and then he just,
this is what you'd do. You do that.
You just humiliate the guy and you just open it up and just say, hey sweetheart,
just want to you, you,
you just write from your heart about what a fucking bitchy is.
And it just is what you do. Don't ever, don't curse in it at all.
Write it really nice and lovely. Um, but in that,
without ever cursing,
just let them know what an absolute fucking pussy is for doing that. They,
you go, oh, that's I think the I, you know what? I think that's a winner.
You know what? I might have to, I might have to outsource this to my listeners.
If you guys have better ideas on what to do there. Nobody gets hurt.
You made your point. It's fucking hilarious. And that's a funny, you know,
you tell people that this guy did it and they go, so what'd you do?
He would tell my, I went out, I went to a lady's too.
She was doing bought bottom a pair of pumps.
Okay.
And then you get to laugh and every time you see him just wave and just start
calling him sweetheart, GIM a pet name.
Maybe you give them a woman's name like Diane or something. Just, hey, Diane,
how'd you like the shoes? And just every fucking day,
you can just do that forever.
I don't know.
It made me feel better about the situation. Maybe you can do that.
Who the fuck knows? Anyways, good luck with that. Uh,
but don't do any physical harm or real property. That's the, the,
the brilliance. I'm a said genius. Pat Myself on the back there.
Sorry about that. Um, that's,
that's what I like about the last plant is that you're not hurting him.
You write it eloquently. You're not cursing. There's nothing he can really do.
You just bought him a gift that you give. You give a woman, it's perfect.
You know, I'd send them some candy on Valentine's Day. Just, Ah,
just torture the guy. But you just keep giving them gifts,
you know?
I don't know. What else? What's The f? Get them some flats.
Okay.
I don't know. It's a bunch of shit like that. I don't know who the fuck knows.
Maybe you just do it once and then that's it. And then what you do.
And then right after that you replant the grass and then you just let them know
that you know that he did it and he's going to be too much of a bitch to try to
do it again. And um,
then he can tell your dad years later that that's don't tell your dad that you
did it and then years later you're telling me you did it when you have an a pint
and you guys can fucking laugh your balls off. Alright, work argument.
Um, hey bill, I work with some real morons.
I'm in sales so everyone is a hotheaded tool. Really.
I thought you guys were like funny. It always seem like the salesman,
we're always breaking balls and being funny. Um,
they all think they're living in a sales movie. Oh, okay. Too many Glen Gary,
Glen Ross. All right.
We have set accounts and nothing about our job requires us to generate new
business from cold leads, but that doesn't stop these tools.
So the other day they're bitching about Saturday night live and how it's not
funny anymore. That's not really a big deal.
People always bitch about SNL even when it's good. That didn't bother me,
but then they all started saying how they'd be funnier on the shell,
you know, Jesus, here we go. This is like maybe watch. No,
I guess it's not like that. All right, let's continue.
I'll just say it took me watching UFC be like, doe. Do you know what?
I want it done. Um,
so this is when I chimed in and told them that it's harder than it looks and
that they did not. They did not.
They did have a shot and that they did have a shot.
Oh, that if she left out a word there said it's harder than it looks.
And if they,
if they did have a shot having no stage presence or x or experience,
they would end up freezing up. Then they'd be the guy who froze up,
whose face was everywhere.
I made the point to them that if they were offered a spot on SNL,
they'd be better to turn it down.
They'd have a happier life if they said no to SNL. Jesus,
do you agree with this? And if you were offered SNL, would you take it? Um,
okay.
Do I think that the people on SNL are funnier than a salesman? Yes, absolutely.
Absolutely. Do I think that they would freeze up now? Not necessarily.
They would probably, you know, maybe a few would freeze up.
Others would get dry mouth and still plow through it. Others would ham it up,
you know, who knows. Um, I dunno. Um,
okay.
There, I mean, if they offered me SNL,
I would know that they were in a lot of trouble.
I'm a 48 year old man next month.
I think that they like to try to get young talent and um,
I think that window was closed.
Okay.
Um, having said that, I've got nothing but respect. It seems like having,
just trying to write a fucking cartoon where we got all the fucking time in the
world to do this shit where they have to come out with a brand new, you know,
90 minutes minus fucking commercials. Um, what's that?
90 minus 24 to get technical eight minutes every half hour.
That's seven 64 fucking 66 minutes a week. Fuck you.
There's no way I've or I've heard nothing, but that's an absolute,
it takes a special personality to be able to do a, to handle that.
And, um,
I would actually be worried about what it would do to my standup career,
having that level of a commitment. Um,
which is why I prefer to do a role in a movie where it's just sort of like,
okay, we got you from here to here. So it's a finite thing.
Without that SNL shit is just like, I don't know when they started,
when they stopped, but it just seems to be a, it's a hell of a commitment. But,
um, yeah, so they go, did I answer your question? Um,
well if you get offered SNL, who says fucking no to that? Um,
I dunno. I Dunno if I get that off. Why am I fucking stressing over this?
It's not happening.
Okay. But
anyways, thank you for sticking up for everybody on SNL. I appreciate that.
All right. Okay.
Here's the last one from a lady from a fucking lady,
a woman proposing Yo baby kegs. Billy Bird. Uh, just curious.
What are your thoughts? What are your, what? Oh,
just curious what your thoughts are. Sorry everybody, I'm bad at this.
Just curious what your thoughts are on women proposing love you.
Thanks for advocating for pitfalls. Hope to see you soon.
Please don't use my name while they never show me your name. Um,
I think that's a bad move on the woman's part.
Uh, I think you guys generally speaking,
are more gun Ho to get married than guys are.
And um,
if you propose to a guy and he's too much of a pussy to say no.
Okay.
Um, and then you, you ended up marrying the wrong person.
I think as a woman you should wait for the fucking guidance.
And I think there's a reason why the guy asks. Um,
it's because we don't want to do it. So if we are actually asking,
then you know, you with the [inaudible], most of them end up in divorce.
You know what, I don't know. Um,
I don't know. That could be maybe be kind of cool. Okay.
There's something cute about it. I can tell you that, not talk it down to you,
but, uh, I used to always fake proposed to Nia
and I used to always go near, I'm proposing to you right now.
And she would always be laughing, going,
I was fucking around and I would always go, I propose that we break up.
It was a silly joke and he used to always make her fucking laugh. Um,
I dunno.
She was real cute during that time when she like wanted me to ask and uh,
I don't know. My wife's fucking adorable. So I mean, what am,
what am I going to do? Um,
took a special kind of fucker woman to trick me into doing this.
She didn't trick me. Anyways, that's the podcast for this week.
I don't know if I have any advertising left anymore, but who gives a fuck?
I never did it for that anyways. Right.
I'll go out and go dance for my supper tonight. I don't need your advertising,
the water money. Although I loved it. Oh, I love that. Advertising whore money.
Maybe I still have it. Who knows? Um, that's the podcast.
Once again. Um, I will try to take some video. Um,
this week I actually made a couple of ones,
but I made one for version and I made one for fucking Dean del Rey,
so it's got their name on it. When I say,
maybe I'll just post those fucking things.
I don't have to fucking move my truck out again, do I? Um, anyways, that's it.
That's a podcast for this week. Thanks for listening. Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check on a Thursday. Let's go blues.